انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بكين تعدوا بخارطه طريق لحل الازمه يعتبر
الحكم على الخطه الصينيه سابقا لاوانه
عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا وباخمت المدمره
تصارع لمواجهه اطول معركه منذ بدء الغزو
التضخم يصل لمستويات قياسيه في ايران وقوه
شراء المواطنين للغذاء تنخفض 70%
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه خطه الطريق
الصينيه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه تسيطر على
الاجواء الدوليه هذه الايام ممثل الصين في
الامم المتحده اكد نابيكين ستطرح عما قريب
ورقه حول طريقه تسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا
مشددا على ان الصين تؤمن بامكانيه حلها
عبر الدبلوماسيه وان ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا فاقم النزاع
الازمات مهما كانت عميقه يمكن حلها بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه في نهايه المطاف ندعم استئناف
روسيا واوكرانيا الحوار المباشر في اسرع
وقت ممكن ووقف اطلاق النار والاعمال
القتاليه ووضع ذلك اولويه ويجب ان يبذل
المجتمع الدولي جهودا مشتركه لتسهيل عمليه
السلام الواقع اثبت ان ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا فقم النزاع ولم يجلب السلام
وندعو ايضا الى التخلي عن استغلال
العقوبات الاحاديه وان يكون البديل العمل
على تعزيز سبل الحوار الصين لطالما لعبت
دورا بناء وستصدر عما قريب ورقه حول طريقه
تسويه الازمه واحلال السلام في وقت مبكر
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه نواشنطن تريد
التعرف على خطه الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا
وتتوقع تسلمها غدا اما الرئيس الاوكراني
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي جمعه برئيس الوزراء
الاسباني
فاكد ان حديث الصين عن اوكرانيا هو ليس
بالامر السيء
لاوانه الحكم على خطه السلام الصينيه
اعتقد بشكل عام ان حقيقه ان الصين بدات
تتحدث عن اوكرانيا وبدات بارسال بعض
الاشارات ليس بالامر السيء من المهم
بالنسبه لنا ان تكون جميع البلدان الى
جانبنا الى جانب العداله ان تتحدث الصين
عن اوكرانيا هو الخطوه الاولى وهذا امر
ليس بسيء
المانيا كانت اقل تفاؤلا حيال هذه المساعي
الصينيه شولتس قال ان الصين لم تتخذ موقفا
من روسيا بعد ويجب عدم التوهم بشان طرح
نفسها وسيطا
نتابع من موسكو مع رائد جبر مدير مكتبي
جريده الشرق الاوسط في موسكو سيد رائد
اهلا بكم معنا بدايه هل تعتقد ان الصين
لديها فرصه لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا من
خلال هذه الوساطه
مساء الخير بدايه الصين يعني دوله وازنه
باعتبار انها تتمتع بعلاقات جيده جدا مع
موسكو ومع الاطراف الاخرى يعني قادره على
اداره حوار مع الدول الاوروبيه مع الاطراف
الاخرى وربما ايضا حتى ما لكن الى اي درجه
يعني حتى الان لم تتضح ملامح
افكار الصينيه صح التعبير
وما اذا كانت يمكن ان تلبي مصالح كل
الاطراف بمعنى انه حتى الان مواقف بكين
يعني كما تعلم لم تكن
ضد موسكو ولكن ايضا لم تعترف الصحيح بضم
القانون الى حد ولكن استاذ رائد يعني كيف
نفهم الحديث عن مبادره صينيه لاحلال
السلام في اوكرانيا لانهاء الحرب ومن جهه
اخرى يثار الحديث على توجه الصين لامداد
روسيا بالاسلحه يعني هل يعني الامريكيون
يتحدثون على انه هناك تحذير للصين من مغبه
تسليم اسلحه الى الى روسيا
فكيف يجتمع الامران
هذا صحيح تماما لكن حتى الان لم تقدم
الولايات المتحده اي اي
دلائل على توفر معلومات بالفعل على
امدادات للاسلحه يعني هناك اتفاقيات
كثيره جدا بين موسكو وبكين حول موضوع
مشتركه ودفاع المشترك وما الى ذلك ولكن لا
يوجد تفاصيل او اثباتات على انه الصين
اليوم تريد بالفعل امداد موسكو بالاسلحه
نحن امام موقف ملتبس هناك بعض الخبراء
بالمناسبه
تحدثون عن انه التصريحات الامريكيه في هذا
الشان هي محاوله لعرقله الدوري الصيني
المحتمل لعرقله اي مبادره صينيه وتاجيج
الموقف حول الصين وليس الاستماع بشكل هادئ
الى الافكار التي يمكن ان تقدمها بكير
خلال هذا عن الغرب لكن ماذا عن روسيا هل
روسيا حقا منفتحه على اي مبادره حتى يعني
المبادره الصينيه والصين طبعا هي اقرب الى
روسيا منها الى المعسكر الغربي حاليا هل
روسيا منفتحه على السلام لانهاء هذه الحرب
بعد عام على بدئها
يعني هذه هي المعضل الحقيقيه انه موسكو
طرحت شروط القاسيه الى حد ما شروط يعني
يمكن وصفها من الجانب الاوكراني ومن
الجانب الغربي انها شروط استسلام للطرف
الاوكراني لذلك يعني هنا يكمل السؤال
الرئيسي وهذا ما حاولت ان اشير اليه في
بدايه الحديث انه الى اي درجه تصير قادره
على طرح مبادره او افكار يمكن ان تنبه
مصرف بمعنى
ان يعني تحترم المصالح الروسيه وهذا امر
مفهوم ولكن هل هذا يعني القبول بمساله ضم
اجزاء من اوكرانيا مثلا هذا امر يعني
مطروح للنقاش ربما تقترح الصين ان يكون
وضع اكرينا محايدا ان يكون هناك ضمانات
روسيه واطلسيه لاوكرانيين في المستقبل
ولكن هناك مشكله الاراضي مشكله يعني
الواقع الميداني الذي نشهده الان الى اي
درجه بالتين قادر على التوصل الى حلول
وصلت اعتقد انه هذه معضله صعبه صعبه نعم
ولكن سيد رائد بعد عام بدء هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا المكاسب الروسيه في هذه الحرب لا
تبدو ترقى الى تلك الطموحات طموحات الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين هل اصلا روسيا مستعده
لديها لاستعداد للاستمرار طويلا في هذه
الحرب يعني استمرار في حرب طويله الامد في
اوكرانيا
يعني دعنا نقول انه اولا كل رجم العقوبات
والضغوط التي مورست على روسيا خلال الفتره
الماضيه خلال العام الماضي لم تؤدي الى
انهيار مثلا الاقتصاد الروسي او الهزات
كبرى في المجتمع الروسي لم نشهد هكذا
اجزات لذلك يبدو ان موسكو قادره على الاقل
لفتره زمنيه معينه قادره على الصمود قادره
على مواجهه هذه الاعباء المتزايده بالتالي
محاوله تحقيق يعني تقدم ميداني اوسع في
منطقه المشكله الرئيسيه او الفكره
الرئيسيه هي انه موسكو يبدو ان حددت
شروطها الان منطقه دومباس
بالاضافه الى خرسون وهذه المناطق الاربعه
التي ضمتها روسيا الخريف الماضي بالاضافه
الى تحييد موضوع شبه جزيره القرم وعدم
العوده الى طرحه على طاوله مفاوضات اصلا
هذا هو الحد الادنى المطروح روسيا حاليا
من اجل الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد جبر انت مدير مكتب جريده
الشرق الاوسط في موسكو
ومن موسكو نذهب الى كيف معنا من هناك
الدبلوماسيه السابق سيد شوماكو اهلا بك
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه رئيس
فلوسي قال انه الحكم على الخطه الصينيه
للوساطه بين روسيا واوكرانيا السابق
لاوانه الحكم عليها بعد هل هذا الكلام
يعني انه الخطه الصينيه للسلام لديها فرصه
ام العكس
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اخوان
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا انا بصراحه
توجد اي افقي هذه اقتراحات صينيه مهمه جدا
بان قبل لم تكون اي مفاوضات مع جانب
اوكرانيا حول هذه اقتراحات الصينيه بصفه
عامه وكمان بصراحه نحن نسمع بعض التصريحات
واقتراحات حول عدم اطلاق النار يعني بصفه
عماير هذا تعني تجميل الصراع هنا في
اوكرانيا واكيد هذا التجميل هي على مصلحه
روسيه الى روسيا ترغب تجميد هذا الصراع
بالمناسبه سنه 2014 عندما روسيا هجمت من
منطقه
غير متاعرفه بها روسيا كمان حققت تنجيمي
الصراع في اوكرانيا وبصراحه التجميد
الصراحه
[موسيقى]
غير مقبوله بصفه عامه كمان كل ضمانات من
روسيا غير كمان مقبول هنا في اوكرانيا
لنتذكر
النوويه من اجل السلام في المعاصر
الان بعد عام على على هذه الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكل تاثيراتها
اوكرانيا كانت تقول وتقول انها لن تفرط في
اي شبر من الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا هل اوكرانيا مستعده للتنازل
قليلا عن هذا الشرط ان هناك تفاوض ربما
الاقتسام بعض المناطق من اجل انهاء هذه
الحرب ام لا هذا خط احمر لا يمكن
لاوكرانيا ان تتنازل عن الاراضي التي
سيطرت عليها روسيا
بصراحه مجتمع اوكرانيا غير مستعد لاي
تنازلات لنتذكر سنه 2014
كانت عندها غرب مثل الرغبه
روسيا باراده اوكرانيا في نهايه
روسيا روسيا ترغب عدم خروج اوكرانيا من
منطقه نفوز روسيه وبهذا كانت عندها رغبه
روسيا عندها روسيا احتلال
غير النظام في اوكرانيا ومده سنه نقول بكل
روسيا فرشه
استراتيجيا هذا حرف اوكرانيا على كل حال
هي سوف تدخل الى نظره وكمان سوف يكون
انضمام اوكرانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي وروسيا
لم تغار من نظام في اوكرانيا بالعكس موجود
توحيد داخل اوكرانيا موجوده توحيد الاصغر
حول قضيه اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك
دبلوماسيه السابق كنت تبعنا من كييف
ومع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
في اوكرانيا يبدو الوضع في ميادين القتال
مختلفا تماما عن الاسابيع الاولى من الحرب
ومغايرا للصوره التي رسمها لمسار المعارك
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه كشفت ان هناك
تقييمات متناقضه لقدره روسيا علشان هجوم
جديد مهم رغم ان كبار المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين حذروا مرارا وتكرارا من ان
موسكو تخطط لبذل جهد جديد كبير هذا العام
على الرغم من التعبئه التي اعلن عنها
بوتين سبتمبر من العام الماضي يعتقد
محللون ان القدرات الروسيه قد تدهورت بسبب
الحرب وان اولئك الذين يتوقعون اعاده
موسكو غزوه جارتها على غرار ما حدث العام
الماضي مخطئون فمنذ اكثر من سته اشهر
تحاول مجموعه فاجنر والجيش الروسي احتلال
مدينه باخموت الواقعه في شرق اوكرانيا ومن
شان الاستيلاء على بخمس ان يمنح القوات
الروسيه نقطه انطلاق للتقدم الى مدينتين
اكبر في الغرب هما اكرم تورسك
[موسيقى]
وفيما تستمر المعارك الداميه وحرب الشوارع
بين روسيا واوكرانيا يحاول جيش الروسي بسط
السيطره على المناطق الاوكرانيه بينما
تتلقى الدعم اللوجستيه والعسكريه الغربي
في مواجهه الدب الروسي في اخر التطورات
الميدانيه قتال الشوارع يحتدم حاليا في
مختلف الجبهات حول باخمت ومعارك مستمره
باسلحه متطوره تدور في المحور الجنوبي
لدنيتك اما بريطانيا فكشفت ان القوات
الروسيه تستعد لهجوم اخر في بلده فوليدار
بمنطقه دومباس الشرقيه حيث تتعرض البلده
لقصف عنيف وتزامنا افادت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه بان قواتها هاجمت مناطق لماسك على
تقوم مقاطعه
ومحيط دونيسكو وجنوب المقاطعه وكبدت الجيش
الاوكراني خسائر بشريه بلغت نحو 500 جندي
فيما لم يصدر عن كييف اي تعليق
وبعد اعلان النيه روسيا تعليق مشاركتها في
المعاهده الروسيه لخفض الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه القى تصريح الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الضوء على القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه وبحسب الاعلام
الروسي فان الكميه الدقيقه للاسلحه
النوويه التي في حوزه روسيا هي من بين
اسرار الدوله فبموجب معاهده ستار ثلاثه
فانه بحلول الخامس من فبراير 2018 كان
اجمالي قدره روسيا النوويه هو
527 وحده لنشر الصواريخ الباليستيه
العابره للقارات والصواريخ الباليستيه
الغواصه والقذفات الثقيله والف 1444 وحده
للرؤوس الحربيه للصواريخ الباليستيه
العابره للقارات والصواريخ الباليستيه
وكذلك للرؤوس الحربيه النوويه
المحتسبه كقاذفات ثقيله
و79 وحده للقاذفات القابله وغير القابله
للنشر والصواريخ الباليستيه العابره
للقارات والاس القبيله وغير القابله للنشر
اما بالنسبه للبيانات الصادره عن معهد
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام فاعتبارا
مي يناير 2022 امتلكت روسيا
5977 راسا نوويا بما في ذلك
1588 تم نشرها على مركبات اطلاق جاهزه
للقتال والفين 289 في حاله توقف
اظهرت لقطات مصوره عبر طائره مسيره كيف
حولت اطول معركه في الغزو الروسيه المستمر
منذ عام مدينه باخموت التي تعمل في
استخراج الملح وانتاج الجص في شرق
اوكرانيا تحويلها الى مدينه اشباح شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
سنه كامله تمر على بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا حملت معها الكثير من الاحداث
والتداعيات التي جاءت تباعا مع تحول
الازمه لحرب بالوكاله بين لاعبي العالم
الكبار
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه على حد تعبير
الكريم خلفت تغييرات عميقه في اوروبا
وازمات جاءت تباعا بدايه من الطاقه الغذاء
والامن صحيفه التلغراف طرحت اربعه
سيناريوهات توضح بالتفصيل كيف يمكن ان
تنتهي حرب بوتين ضد اوكرانيا
السيناريو الاول يطرح فكره تحول الصراع
الحاصل الى حرب ابديه قد تستمر لشهور او
سنوات طويله يخوض فيها الطرفان حرب
استنزاف مديده تتارجح بين المكاسب تاره
والخسائر تاره اخرى دون الاستسلام اما
السيناريو الثاني فيطرح فكره وقف الدماء
اذا اتفقت طرفان على وقف اطلاق النار الذي
من شانه ان يجمد الوضع السياسي والاقليميه
الراهن حيث ان هذه الخطوه ستقلل العبء
الاجماليه على عاتق المدنيين في اوكرانيا
غير انها لن تحل الاسباب الاستراتيجيه
الكامنه وراء الصراع
السيناريو الثالث يطرح فكره الوحده
الروسيه حيث يمكن للهجمات المضاده الروسيه
الناجحه في التدمير المستمر للبنى التحتيه
الحيويه في اوكرانيا ان تمكن موسكو من
تعزيز مكاسبها الاقليميه على الاقل فيما
يتعلق بالاقاليم الاوكرانيه الاربعه التي
تم ضمها
السيناريو الرابع يطرح فكره النصر
الاوكراني في الميدان من خلال اجبار
القوات الروسيه على الانسحاب الى المواقع
التي كانت تنتشر فيها قبل بدايه الحرب
ويكون من خلال شن اوكرانيا هجمات مضاده
وبتحويل جيشها من قوه دفاعيه الى قوه
هجوميه
هذه السيناريوهات تقابلها تطورات ميدانيه
متسارعه في اقليم دومباس معارك عنيفه دون
تغيير كبير في الخريطه لكن ربما تتغير هذه
الخريطه قريبا بحلول فصل الربيع
[موسيقى]
في اول مقابله من نوعها لوسيله اعلاميه
عربيه قالت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى
انه لا احد يجهزك كسيده الاولى خصوصا في
زمن الحرب مضيفه لها تحاول كل جهدها
للانتصار في هذه الحرب ضد روسيا
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا
احد يجهزك على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده
اولى خصوصا في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك
لحقيقه انه يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله
في حاله حرب ولكن كما قال داروين ليس
الاسرع او الاقوى من ينجو ولكن اولئك
الذين يمكنهم التكيف لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل
وفق متطلبات العصر حسب مقتضيات الظروف
التي نعيش فيها احاول ان افعل كل ما يجب
علي من اجل تقريب انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر
اهميه هو التحدث عن اوكرانيا عن
الاوكرانيين في اي منصه حيث اتيحت للفرصه
للتحدث
وتحدثت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى للعربيه عن
لحظه الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا انه تم
من كل الجهات ودون سابق انذار مشيره الى
انها كانت لحظه انفصال عائلتها منشغال
زوجها الرئيس لينسكي بالحرب
لقد هجموا علينا حقا من جميع الجهات في
الصباح الباكر وكان اصعب شيء بالنسبه لي
هو كيف اقول للاطفال كان علي ان اذهب الى
الغرفه وايقظهم واخبرهم بان الحرب قد بدات
لكن لحسن الحظ لقد استيقظوا بالفعل وفهموا
بالفعل كل شيء لم يكن علي ان اخبرهم باي
شيء ومنذ تلك اللحظه بدا زمن فيصل عائلتنا
بعد ذلك لم يروا والدهم الا بعد بضعه اشهر
اليوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى نتذكر ذلك
التاريخ لا يوجد تاريخ انتهاء لهذه الحرب
لكن لها تاريخ بدء وكان ذلك في الربع
والعشرين من فبراير من العام الماضي وسوف
نتذكر دائما هذا اليوم الرهيب
ومع الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تتعالى الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بالاخطاء التي ارتكبها صحيفه
لابرز الاخطاء التي ارتكبها
قبل الحرب وبعدها
هنا في الجنوب الاوكراني وتحديدا في منطقه
خيرسون وقف الرئيس الاوكراني قبل عام يهدئ
من هلع مواطنيه جراء الاخبار عن الحشود
الروسيه على طول حدود البلاد
اليوم وبعد عام من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تعود الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بما تسبب به للبلاد ليس كمسبب
للحرب بل على تجاهله الاعمى للتحذيرات من
غزو روسي كان وشيكا ومن الاخطاء التي
اعادت البلاد الى ايام الحرب العالميه او
اسوا يتذكر الاوكرانيون جيدا كيف وقف
رئيسهم هنا يدعوهم لعدم الضعر كان ذلك قبل
ان تصبح المنطقه باكملها بيد الروس فيما
عدا المدينه
يجب ان اتحدث مع شعبنا كرئيس واقول للناس
الحقيقه والحقيقه هي ان لدينا معلومات
مختلفه لكن افضل صديق للاعداء هم
المذعورون في بلدنا وكل هذه المعلومات
تساعد فقط فيه خلق حاله الذعر ولا تساعدنا
نحن
وحكومته كان منشغلين بملاحقه الخصوم
السياسيين بتهمه الخيانه امر اثار استياء
الحلفاء الغربيين حينها وعندما بدات الحرب
لم يجد الاوكرانيون ما يدافعون به عن
انفسهم ورغم الحرب عاد الفساد ينخر حكومه
زيلينسكي وطفت على السطح قضايا فساد
مرتبطه بكبار مسؤول الحكومه والجيش اعترف
بها الرئيس في العالم
اليوم شهد الاوكرانيون مجموعه اخرى من
القرارات بشان الموظفين الفاسدين اؤكد على
اننا سنستمر في العمل على اي قضايا داخليه
تعوق الدوله الاوكرانيه من اجل الدفاع عن
البلاد والجهود المبذوله للتقرب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي رغم التاييد والتعاطف
الدولي للزلنسكي لا تبدو اوكرانيا بين حرب
وفساد باحسن حال في عهده ليس بسبب غزو
روسيا بل لان اداره لا تشبه التمثيل
والكوميديا وهو ما يقوله منتقد ومعارضوا
الرجل
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد الرئاسه
الفراغ قد يكون مصير المناصب الامنيه في
لبنان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في ايران ازمات من كل
حدب وصوب تظاهرات تعكس غضب الشارع من نظام
الحكم الاستبدادي يتزامن مع ازمه اقتصاديه
خانقه تجاوز فيها مؤشر التضخم 50% في
الشهر الحالي للمره الخامسه خلال عام
واحده ويظهر هذا المؤشر ان الاسر
الايرانيه انفقت اكثر من 53% على شراء نفس
السلع والخدمات في فبراير الجاري مقارنه
بالفتره نفسها من العام الماضي ومع قيام
الحكومه بالغاء التسعيد الحكومي للدولار
واجه سوق المواد الغذائيه صدمه اسعار
كبيره وبلغ معدل التضخم في المنتجات
الغذائيه 86% منذ بدايه الصيف
[موسيقى]
معنى باباك امام يانا الخبير في الشؤون
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه سيدنا ماميان شكرا
لك على انضمامك الينا في اخبار الساعه هذه
الليله من العربيه ما هي العوامل التي ادت
الى ارتفاع التضخم بهذا الشكل في ايران
شكرا على ترحيل هذا السؤال
سوء الاداره الكلي فان سوى اداره الاقتصاد
كان جزءا اما الجزء الاخر فهو زياده
مضطرده في عدد المؤسسات التي تمتلكها
الحكومه
في الثوره السابقه في تسعه عام تسعه
وسبعين كان هناك اكثر من 50 مؤسسه تدير
شؤون البلاد والان
يوجد اكثر من 150 مؤسسه اي ثلاثه اضعاف
الرقم هذا يتكبدوا تكاليف اضافيه للحكومه
على مر العقود الاربعه الماضيه مما رفع
التكلفه والارتفاع العجز وجعل الحكومه
اكثر فقرا
وخلق وظائف وهميه اكثر من مليون وظيفه وفي
الاونه الاخيره النظام قد فقد شرعيته
وبالتالي قد فقد شعبيته وعندما يفقد هو
النظام الشرعيه ويفقد الشعبيه فان التكلفه
تصبح باهضه لماذا
لانه يتوجب عليه الان ان يدير شؤون البلاد
بالبندقيه
وتكلفه اداره البلاد من فوهه البندقيه امر
مكلف
لكن اود ان انهي كلامي بان النظام لم يعد
يمتلكه على اموال طائله التي تدفعه لتغطيه
نفقات القوات الامنيه وهناك حاله من
التضارب بين الموظفين الدائمين والموظفين
المؤقتين في الخدمات الامنيه لان الموظفين
المؤقتين يدفعوا لهم اربعه مرات اعلم من
الموظفين الدائمين حاله الصراع والنزاع
هذه اتدعو للسخريه لان الموظفين الدائمين
في القوات الامنيه قد يتوجهون للاضرار لكن
سيد امام هذه نقطه مهمه جدا ذكرتها ان
الحكومه باتت اكثر فقرا بسبب العوامل التي
عدتها هل اثر هذا على انفاقها على الجانب
العسكري والامني ان كان داخليا في ايران
او كان بالنسبه للميليشيات التي ينظمها
النظام الايراني خارج الحدود الايرانيه
انت محق تماما نحن نعلم هذا النظام فهو لن
يتوان
لا يقوم بانفاق الاموال على رفاهي شعوب بل
يقوموا بانفاقها من اجل احداث الفوضى
والدمار في كل مكان هذا ما يرغب به النظام
وفي الفتره الحاليه هناك بعض المفاوضات
التي تتعلق باطلاق سراح الرهائن الرهينه
الامريكيين
وقامت كوريا الجنوبيه بتجميد سبعه
مليارات دولار
تمتلك النظام هناك الامريكيون يقولون انه
اذا ما تم تجميد هذا ما تم رفع تجميد هذا
الاصول فقد تاتي بطريقه معدات طبيه وغذاء
لكن النقطه هي ان هذا النظام خبير في
التلاعب فقد يقوم بتحويل الغذاء والمعدات
الطبيه
وتحويلها الى اموال للمزيد من الميليشيات
واحداثه المزيد من الفوضى في العالم
سيدي مومياء هناك من يقول ان الازمه
الاقتصاديه الحاليه هي لا تمس ايران او لا
تضرب ايران فقط بل تضرب عديد دول العالم
خاصه الدول الناميه في ظل طبعا الحرب في
اوكرانيا
وتداعياتها
مؤخرا هل برايك النظام الايراني في ظل
يعني هذه الازمه الخانقه يمكن ان يتغير
يغير من تعاطيه ان كان مع موضوع العقوبات
او ان كان من ناحيه يعني تغيير توجهاته في
تحسين ظروف الاقتصاد الداخليا في ايران
اشكرك على كونك متفائلا بعض الشيء لكن
استطيع ان اقول لك بانه ما من امل مع
واجهه مع وجود هذا النظام فهذا النظام لن
يتغير لان الجرم هو
هو شيء يسري في عروق فهو قد جاء الى سده
السلطه كالتنظيم ارهابي اذا ما اخذت بلدا
ما وتكون نسبه الجرائم فيه عاده بين واحد
وثلاثه في المئه بالشكل الطبيعي لكن في
ايران والنظام الايراني ومؤيده كانوا قد
رفعوا نسبه الجرميه الى 20% لاعداد السكان
هذه هي المشكله التي تواجهها ايران ان
نسبه التجريم قد ارتفعت الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه الى درجه درجه تصل ان 20% هم في
عداد المجرمين سواء كان ذلك بصوره مقصوده
او غير مقصوده بسبب انشطه جرميه
باباك امام الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه
والاقتصاديه شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي الثاني من مارس يحال المدير العام
للامن العام لواء عباس ابراهيم في لبنان
نتحدث سيحال عباس ابراهيم للتقاعد هو رغم
رغبتي حزب الله بالتمديد له الا ان التيار
الوطني الحر رفض تامين نصاب جلسه تشريعيه
لتعديل قانوني يبقيه في منصبه واستطخوف من
ان ينسحب الفراغ الرئاسي على مناصب امنيه
اساسيه في لبنان
في دوامه من الفراغات يدور لبنان الذي دخل
شهره الرابع بدون رئيس للجمهوريه
الكرسي الرئاسي الذي شكل السبب الابرز خلف
خلاف حزب الله والتيار الوطني الحر حال
ايضا دون تامين نصاب جلسه تشريعيه نيابيه
لتفادي فراغ في منصب المدير العام للامن
العام
اللواء عباس ابراهيم يحال على التقاعد في
الثاني من مارس وفي حال عدم التمديد
الابراهيم يحال المنصب الى العميد رمز
الرامي المحسوب على التيار الوطني الحر مش
الخلاف على اسم اللواء عباس ابراهيم
الخلاف هو على مبدا التشريع بغياب رئيس
الجمهوريه او عقد جلسه لمجلس الوزراء
بغياب رئيس الجمهوريه وحتى التمديد لانه
الحزب ما جرى جبران باسيل بالتمديد لبعض
المدراء العامين مثل رورفالي ابن فهلا
جبران مثل بيقولوا بلبنان عم بيرد عم بيرد
العمليه هي ذاتها هلا للحزن بس بنهايه
المطاف يبدو انه في الا ما يكون في مخارج
يعتمدوا عليها التمديد العباسيد الوطني
ونشيده الامن العام خلف الكواليس اتصالات
واجتماعات لايجاد حلول لتفادي الشهور في
اكثر من موقع امني بينها منصب قائد الجيش
الذي اعلن عن عدم رغبته في التمديد ومنصب
المدير العام لقوى الامن الداخلي اللواء
عماد عثمان الذي ابدى النواب السنه ر في
التمديد له مخرج الاهم والذي يطفو هو
مبدئيا مخرج استدعاء اللواء ابراهيم من
الاحتياط ارتكازا على قانون تعليق المهن
وصولا الى اعتباره القاضي او القائد
الاعلى رتبه وبالتالي يتسلم مهام الامن
العام مجددا ولكن هذه مبدئيا التخريجه
التي يبحث عنها ايضا مشوبه
بكثير من العيوب والتي يمكن ان تؤدي الى
طلب ابطاله امام الجيش الثوره الدولي وكان
نواب الاعتدال الوطني قد تقدموا باقتراح
قانون هدفه تجنب الفراغ في مراكز امنيه
حساسه بغياب اي مؤشرات لحل سياسي يحاول
المعنيون ايجاد صيغه قانونيه غير قابله
للطعن لتفادي فراغ جديد بعد التمديد في
معركه مستمره بين حلفاء على شفير التحول
لاعداء غنوه يتيم العربيه بيروت
مشاهدينا ننتقل بكم الى الامم المتحده في
نيويورك حيث تصوت الجمعيه العمل الامم
المتحده الان في هذه اللحظات على مشروع
قرار يدين الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
انتقل الان الى مشروع التعديل في الوثيقه
اي على اي احد عشر على التسعه
طلب تصويت مسجل على مشروع التعديل a على
اي احد عشر على التسعه سنبدا عمليه
التصويت الان ارجو من الوفود المؤيده
لمشروعي
التعديل
التسعه ان تعلن ذلك تلك المعارضه وتلك
الممتلئه جميع العامه تصوت الان على مشروع
التعديل على ايه تسعه
نرجو من كل الوفود ان تتحقق نصاحه برود
اصواتها على الشاشه
اغلق الجهاز
نتيجه التصوير هي كالتالي المؤيده 15
المعارضه 91
الممتنعه 52 مشروع التعديل على اي احد عشر
على التسعه لم يعتمد
بما ان مشروع
التعطيلين ايه على اي اساس 11 الثمانيه
علي احد عشر التسعه لم يعتمد سنه توجهوا
الان البت في مشروع القرار على احد عشر
على السبعه
الجمعيه العامه ستعمل الان على البث في
مشروع القرار على اي اس احد عشر السبعه
بعنوان واقتبس مبادئ وميثاق الامم المتحده
التي تقوم عليها التي يقوم عليها السلام
الشامل والعادل والدائم في اوكرانيا نهايه
اختبار
طلب تسجيل تصويت مسجل سنبدا عمليه التصويت
الان الوفود المؤيده لمشروع القرار ايه
على اي اساس 11 السبعه نرجو منها ان تعلن
تاييدها وتلك ممتعه وتلك
المعارضه
الجمعيه العامه تصوت الان على مشروع
القرار ايه على اي اساس 11 على 7
بعنوان مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده التي
يقوم عليها السلام الشامل والعادل ودائمه
في اوكرانيا
ارجو من كل الوفود ان تتحقق من صحه ظهور
اصواتها على الشاشه
نرجو اغلاق الجهاز
نتيجه التصويت كالتالي
المؤيده
141 دوله المعارضه سبعه
الممتنعه اثنين وثلاثون مشروع القرار على
117 اعتمد
دي فوقي قبل اعطاء الكلمه
بعد التصويت اذكر الوفود الموقره ان تعديل
التصويت بعشر دقائق وتدلي به الوفود من
مقاعدها
الكلمه الان
لمندوبي او مندوبه
سيدي الرئيس
عن استقلاليه الدول وسلامه اراضيها
وسيادتها وحق الشعوب تقرير المصير ونحن
نعرض
بالكامل استخدام القوه او تهديد بذلك
ونؤيد تسويه السلميه لنزاعاتي والخلافات
قبل عام مضى تقريبا وفي هذه الجمعيه
العامه حذرنا من ان التاريخ سوف
يطالب
الحكومه الامريكيه بتحمل مسؤوليه نتائج
نظاما عسكريا يمتد خرج حدودها ويهدد
السلامه والامن والاستقرار على المستوى
الدولي في اوكرانيا اليوم
وبدلا من تخفيف من حده التوترات فقد
ازدادت حدث المواجهات ميدانيا عبر التزايد
في نقل الاسلحه والخطابه العدائيه وفرد
الجزيئات احاديه الطرف مما يساهم في تمديد
امادي الصراع لقد امتنعت كيوبا عن التصويت
على مشروع القرار السبعه
وجدنا ان هذا القرار لن يساهم في تحقيق
الحوار ولن يفي غرض المفاوضات بمشاركه كل
اطراف المعنيه بهدف الوصول الى سلام
صادقا وعادل
وان هذا السلام هو مطلوب مطلوب وبالحاح
اليوم لا يمكن لنا ان نؤجج من نيران صراع
ان يتسبب يوما بعد يوم بسقوط القتلى
والجرحى والالحاق الضرر المادي ترفض بلادي
اي محاوله لتلاعب هذا النص كاساس قانونيا
لتبرير اقامه محاكم في المستقبل تهدف الى
اجراء محاكمه على المستوى الوطني والدولي
ليس للجمعيه العامه ولايه لتفعل ذلك ان
كيوبا مستمره بمدافعتها
المستمره ومطالبتها بحل دبلوماسي يكون
واقعيا لتسويه الاثبات في اوكرانيا عبر
سبل سلميه
وفي اطار القانون الدولي الذي يضمن امن
وسياده الجميع
والسلام والامن على المستويين الاقليمي
والدولي وشكرا اشكروا مندوبه كيوبا الموقر
وقبل اعطاء الكلمه للمتحدثه التالي اطلبوا
من الوفود الموقره ان
تتحدث بصوت هادئ نرجو منكم ان تحترموا كل
المتحدثين نشكركم على حسن تفهمكم والكلمه
الان
لمندوب جمهوريه مصر العربيه الموقر شكرا
جزيلا سيد الرئيس نشكرك على
سيد الرئيس سيد الرئيس
ايضا مشاهده الكرام نكتفي بهذا القدر من
جلسه التصويت في الامم المتحده اذا جرى
التصويت على مشروع قرار يدين الغزو الروسي
في اوكرانيا عشيه مرور عام على بدء هذه
العمليه العسكريه هناك اذا مشاهدينا نذهب
الان الى فاصل في اخبار الساعه بعدها نعود
ونتابع راشد الغنوشي قيد التحقيق بقضايا
ارهاب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذنت النيابه العامه
التونسيه باطلاق سراح رئيس حركه النهضه
راشد الغنوشي الذي مثل امام وحده مكافحه
الارهاب بالحرس الوطني بالعوينه حيث تم
سماع اقواله بخصوص شكوى قدم بها ضده لقبي
امني على خلفيه وجود تسجيل صوتي الاجتماعي
انضم الغنوشي بقيادات من تنظيم انصار
الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في تونس
الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز اخبارها
بخارطه طريق لحل الازمه
يعتبر الحكم على الخطه الصينيه سابقا
لاوانه
عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا وباخمه المدمره
تصارع لمواجهه اطول معركه منذ بدء الغزو
سيده اوكرانيا الاولى تصف للعربيه لحظه
الهجوم الروسي على كييف وجهودها لانتصار
اوكرانيا في الحرب
التضخم يصل لمستويات قياسيه في ايران وقوه
شراء المواطنين للغذاء تنخفض 70%
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده نجد دائما يبقى
على العربيه على صفحتنا على تويتر فيسبوك
ويوتيوب غدا نلقاكم في تغطيه خاصه لمرور
عام على الحرب الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]